he did it crazy son of a did it
again
what am I talking about jurgen
schmidhuber reinforcement learning
upside-down new paper just dropped on
the verge of the Nerds conference being
presented at a workshop here presenting
upside-down reinforcement learning I am
pumped for this one can you tell so it's
as we transform reinforcement learning
into a form of supervised learning by
turning traditional oral on its head
calling this our flower
why don't we kind of call this let's
just call it Laura upside down
reinforcement learning and so this is
this is upside down never mind
okay let's just check out how how it
works so so I'm going to give a brief
over you'll be going before we go gonna
go into this paper all right so let's
say you have a reinforcement learning
problem let's say an Atari game for
example and in an Atari game usually
have a screen right and let's just say
you're playing this this marine
commander so there's water here right
and there might be a bunch of um here's
your boat right there's a boat what
about there might be a bunch of
opponents right here fishy fish
opponents fishy fish opponents and so on
and a bunch of gold coins like here
that's a big gold coin right and you're
kind of supposed to I don't I think
you're supposed to like go get air you
have some air meter over here whatever
so there's this Atari game right we're
supposed to get the reward which is this
may be this this coin here and stay
alive as long as possible and so on so
this is classic reinforcement learning
problem and there are various techniques
for this we've looked at a couple of
them and wood upside down reinforcement
learning does is basically what you do
is you want to transform this input to a
new representation which basically well
if I can
maybe I can let me get this correctly so
and there's this over here and then
there's a little fishy a little fishy
here and there's a coin right here so
what you want to do is basically turn
this input on its head like upside down
and so this way is kind of up or down
whatever in this new representation and
if you actually learn on this new
representation um with really the same
techniques it works much better than the
classic RL setting and this is not only
for like these Atari games like this
this appears to hold throughout the RL
space so in robotics like if you have a
robot whatever this is a robot it has a
square head as you can tell you know
it's supposed to like open the door
you've seen this DARPA challenge this
doesn't work right but if you just
transform this and actually turn the
robot turn the robot upside down that
the robot will be able like to open the
door just fine and even like if you have
a chessboard and there's like a bunch of
pieces on it the problem in this case is
you have to so you need to simulate this
chessboard and if you turn this if you
turn this around now you basically all
the pieces will fall off so what you
need to do is you need to have a
simulator that encodes a magnetic chess
board such that the pieces don't fall
off but so it's a bit of programming
effort but if you do that all right
I'm kidding this it is a new paradigm
for all RL but it's unfortunately it's
not as good though someone should try
the magnetic chessboard simulator upside
down RL is a new paradigm for RL we're
basically the kind of notion of inputs
and outputs of the RL algorithm are
switched around a bit so basic ideas
here is
is a that you have an RL algorithm that
is also fed with a bunch of commands so
in classic or L what you'll have and
let's actually go back do this to this
Atari game here right in classic RL and
RL algorithm we'll get the Atari game as
in that the screen as an input and is
asked from this to predict a bunch of
outputs so in classic Atari these are
eight actions in a row three here like
go to the left go to the right or press
the button for shoot right these are the
actions you have and the algorithm is
tasked and there are different versions
of this in policy methods policy
gradient methods typically the algorithm
is tasks without putting a distribution
over these actions with in other methods
like value learning Q learning the
algorithm is tasked with assigning each
of these actions a value so it's a in
this situation going to the left will be
worth three in the future it is going to
the right will be worth negative one and
shooting will be worth zero so you might
want to go with the with the this this
action here right now in upside down
reinforcement learning so we've had
right we've had observation going into
the model and the model coming up with
the value estimation of the different
actions in upside-down reinforcement
learning you'll have the observation and
something else going into the model and
the model coming up with an action
alright and this something else is the
key what you input here is your desire
your future desire and in this paper
they call it a command so you'll have a
command as an input together with the
observations you basically say here's my
state and I would like to achieve let's
say five reward in the next five reward
in the next two time steps right make
this happen right this is this is your
command
going into the model and the model will
then try to find
actions such that in the next two time
steps you'll get five reward you can
easily see a model that learns this will
actually be able to you know do various
things including doing the classic RL
things like get as much reward as
possible in given or in the shortest
amount of time but can also do much more
and in the general sense the difference
is how this is terrain now this model
when you train it as you can see you
don't it's not trained with in my having
in mind kind of only to get the maximum
reward it is trained to be much more a
general kind of understanding of the
world
I mean learning what do I need to do to
achieve a variety of goals specifically
what you want to do to train this is the
following say you have a method of of
moving in the world and collecting
traces right so you go from state state
one state to state three you go with
like your action one action to let's
draw action three the state four and in
each of these you get a you get rewards
right reward one reward to reward three
now this in classic RL this will kind of
give you one training example right so
this is if you consider this to be an
episode this will give you one training
example to to run the sequence of
actions upside down RL you can actually
consider this as many many training
examples and here's what I mean so if
you for example start at state 1 you can
say aha within one time step one one
time step I go to state two and I have
achieved r1
rewards by doing action a1 right so this
now can be an input to your model your
model could learn if you get as an
observation you remember the previous
thing as an observation you get s1 as a
command you get I want to achieve in one
time step r1 reward right and you train
this goes into the model and the model
is trained to say a1 given if I am in s1
and I do a 1 I will achieve that right
so you train the model to give a 1 as an
output and this is valid because in the
past you've observed going from s1 using
a 1 to a state where you get this this
kind of reward in this kind of time but
you can also so you can do all of these
single steps they will all provide
individual training examples to your
model right but then also you can
consider to step things you can say I'm
in state s1 and I go I go in two time
steps I have achieved r1 plus r2 reward
by doing actions a1 then a 2 right and a
- I'm going to do any parents here
because what you want to do is you want
to always consider the action that comes
right after where you are now so again
your training sample let me draw this up
here maybe your training sample would be
the following I am in state s1 this will
be my observation my command would be I
would like to achieve in two time steps
reward r1 plus r2 reward right this
reward this both goes into the model
right you tell the model please given
the state s1 achieve this reward in this
time and the model is supposed to output
a 1 saying AHA in the past I was in this
state and I did achieve this goal by
using that so the model is
supposed to learn to achieve different
goals right so now you can not only
train from good episodes right you can
train from any episode any episode
usually in classic RL you kind of want
to focus on the good episodes because
you want to maximize your reward but
here you can tell the model hey if you'd
done something particularly stupid let's
say here in in s3 you've done something
the a3 was particularly stupid gave you
that so r3 here was a really bad reward
like a negative 5 billion trillion and
you can actually train the model to
wreck to recognize this converter Hey
look if you are in s3 and within one
times that you want to achieve negative
five billion billion billion trillion
reward you all you have to do is action
a3 right and then the cool thing now is
if you are at evaluation time you
actually want the big reward what you'll
do is you simply plug in a different
command simply in one time step still
I'm in state s3 in one time step I want
to achieve actually three reward not
negative a lot right and the model will
have learned that a3 will lead to a
situation where you get a lot of
negative rewards so the model will be
like I'm for sure not going to do a 3
right I'm going to do something else
here because I have learned to map a 3 2
like this really low reward so in
essence this has connections to things
like hindsight experience replay and a
kind of universal value function where
you kind of learn to go from any state
to any other state in this but none of
these do none of these have this kind of
command what the schmidhuber calls
command here as an input to the model
and I think actually this is this is
really positive to input this because
usually in universal value functions
what you would say is let's consider a
simple grid world right
whatever your agent is here and you need
to you need to reach a goal that's down
here
but you might not be able to learn it
because it's super sparse reward and so
on but what you can do is you can learn
to reach this position in this position
in this position from various positions
like go here go from here to here you
can learn to go from here to here and
you know in essence you would like it
eventually to generalize to all the
fields so you basically learn to go from
any position to any other position with
your agent what is universal value or
universal policy functions having sub
goals but they during that phase where
they learn to go from anything to
anything they don't they don't
necessarily include this reward thing as
in as an input it's more like kind of a
either a sub goal or like the usual
value function will simply approximate
the reward whereas whereas in this
technique we actually have a policy
learning we actually output a an action
value also hindsight experience replay
what hindsight experience replay would
do in the same situation right you're
here we might do a videos on this in the
future you're here and you try right and
your agent actually ends up here right
ends up right here what you can do is
you can simply say oh well actually this
this was my goal all along and then
simply a train train your model as if as
if this thing here was your goal all
along and not this thing here and treat
it as kind of a positive reward for this
at least that's how I understand it
right and both of these things are quite
different than here where we have this
command isn't but and I I do I do like
it so I think this this simp this is
very much the the basic things here this
it is extra extrapolated to kind of
noisy inputs noisy environments and so
on but this is the the basic the basic
gist of it so
here you see you're you what you will
learn is to map all and all is your
representation of your input so the
screen for example or the chessboard and
I think also kind of the last action
under where you get in this step plus
your horizon and desire so in how much
time you would like to achieve how much
reward and then you can also get in put
some extra goals that you have and so
you can see basically any any episode
that you've run in the past will give
you a valid training example for this
year model will simply learn to match
the previous experience with the goals
that were achieved in the previous
experience so there is lots of lots of
generalizations here like how exactly
these things are represented this this
time horizon can be a high dimensional
object desire can be as I understand it
somewhat I dimensional object the extra
commands can be like conditionals on
these two things it gets very
complicated but I want to jump ahead to
a different paper where so this paper is
basically just describing the algorithm
and then the next paper is doing
experiments with this let's scroll past
year alright so this paper training
agents using up that down reinforcement
learning released on the same day but
different authors that have used also
automate who is also here but have used
this to implement a variant of this and
here you see again what I was trying to
to explain so in traditional or LD is
especially here cue learning you will
have this function will sketch an
observation as input and then q-learning
especially you also get action as an
input you're supposed to say for the
given observation this particular action
has this expected value as a return
right that's what I explained at the
beginning that's kind of value-based
reinforcement learning
whereas the behavior function here which
would be upside down reinforcement
learning gets the observation and a
command and we'll map that to an action
and here again is what we've gone over
this is a bit of a different thing so
this agent has apparently run two
different episodes one point it did this
sequence of actions and at the other
point from the same starting state it
did this sequence of action and you can
see here on the right
all the training samples we can we can
derive from this so we can say from
state s0 right if I want to return in
one time step I have experiences in the
past right to return in one time step
all I have to do is take action a1 but
if I want one return in one time step I
have to take action a two and you teach
your behavior function to learn these
things to learn to output these actions
with these things here as inputs and
then what you hope of course is that
this will generalize that it will learn
to generalize that you can say now give
me more reward than I have ever seen
before
right and it will kind of learn which
things correspond to lower reward which
things correspond to higher reward and
we'll be able to extrapolate which
things will correspond to even higher
report reward sorry so they have two
algorithms and this is kind of this is
reminiscent of the old of the old RL
kind of world where you do kind of one
algorithm is continuously learning from
the experience gathered by another
algorithm so you have one set of
algorithms and this even in modern RL
this this this is how it's done right
you have two different boxes right
actually you have probably one box
learning the model like this is I'm
gonna represent this here learner right
and the learner distributes the model to
many many machines interacting with
simulators and these machines all they
do is run episodes with the learned
model and they will send back their
experience here and then the learner can
learn from it and then at the end send
it again so so all right here we go
so in each step what we do in order to
to generate a new episode we don't
always want to want to kind of execute
one given policy what we do is we sample
from the end of the replay buffer and
the replay buffer is sorted by returns
right so the highest return episodes are
on top so we want to sample the highest
return episodes then we want to say
maybe some of them are ten steps long
maybe some of them are five steps long
and so on so we set the horizon to be
the mean of the lengths of these right
and we set the desired return how much
return should be achieved in this time
to read the units to sample from the
uniform distribution between M and M
plus s and M is the mean and s is the
standard deviation of the selected
episodic return so what this means is is
like here's a bunch of episodes from
they start at the same time here's a
bunch of episodes that I ran right from
here is time zero and then time goes on
that I ran that had really high returns
right now I'm gonna take the mean time
that these episodes ran like this this
is maybe five time steps so in five time
I want to achieve
now how much reward now you look at all
the rewards that were achieved this is
maybe a distribution that has some mean
here like so and then you say I want to
achieve a reward between here and one
standard deviation hi
here so right and this this would be the
reward you want to achieve so you do is
you kind of your push you're a learned
model to just go a bit beyond what it
has seen so far is basically say look I
you can do this but you can just do a
bit more in the same amount of time
please do this and you hope the model
has learned to kind of generalize to do
this and if so you will execute these
episodes and then these episodes will go
back to the learner right will go back
to the learner here and the learner will
learn from them and hopefully then you
can like generalize even more and then
you can say I know how to achieve this
bit more reward now I can if I run the
episode I will achieve even more reward
I can push them all even further right
so at eval time you can always ask the
model to produce as much reward as
possible in the given time and of course
every episode sent back here is not only
one training example as we saw but many
many training examples can be derived
from these models even beyond what's in
what's in this paper alright so I think
this was a good first shot at describing
this algorithm I hope you get the gist
of it I enjoy this a bit of a criticism
for me would be it still kind of doesn't
it so it doesn't touch the exploration
dilemma so it again deals with kind of
incremental incrementally getting better
whereas I feel this can easily get stuck
in some minimum where it's not possible
to do this incremental generalization of
the model where you really need a new
approach and that's why games like
Montezuma's Revenge are solved using
algorithms like go explore and not any
of the classic algorithms that being
said they have experiments where they
show that especially in sparse reward
environments they do better than classic
orell algorithms so if you for example
here take the lunar lander where a 2 C
beats upside down RL
um I guess you didn't get map blood
lipids here to do the upside down or
hell
well the in other gear in other
environments upside down or I'll clearly
beats the classic algorithms and what I
like here is they took a lunar lander
and the witch which basically every time
step you get a reward in lunar lander
and they hypothesized okay this is
really good for these classic algorithms
that do reward maximization instead of
kind of learning this general behavior
function and what they did is they
modified the game such that all the
reward is given at the end of the
episode and then you see that upside
down or L will actually outperform here
the classic things where it's exactly
the same game you just get the reward at
the end so upside down or L kind of
learns the structure of the world learns
that you get this reward at the end
after such-and-such many time steps so
you can it will learn please get me zero
reward in fifty time steps like no
problem but please get me a thousand
rewards in a hundred time steps no
problem I just go to the end of the
episode right whereas these pure reward
maximization techniques they don't they
they somehow have a harder time to do
that I like this investigation I like
the thinking outside the box
the schmidhuber ism of the paper it's
just all great it's a great time to be
alive and check this out and I'll see
you bye-bye